so there was a story told at the uh at a
house Judiciary Committee meeting
yesterday that I think everyone needs to
hear and you've probably heard me
mention it a time or two but uh when we
talk about miscarriages of Justice we
talk about the Federal Government
Federal Agencies being weaponized
against their political opponents there
are some really egregious examples of
this that we that we discuss many of
them targeting Donald Trump
but this story I think is
arguably worse than all of that is daily
wire reporting acquitted Catholic
pro-life activist Mark Houck in front of
the house Judiciary uh committee on
Tuesday Revisited the moment when
federal and state law enforcement
authorities raided his home with guns
last year on accusations that he blocked
others from entering an abortion clinic
halcu leads a non-profit group that
counsels women outside of abortion
clinics in Philadelphia uh testified in
front of the subcommittee members during
a hearing to revisit the implications of
the face act which is a federal law
prohibiting people from blocking others
from entering abortion clinics and also
to examine recent attacks on pregnancy
centers pro-life facilities and the bite
administration's use of the federal
statute
now Halk was acquitted in January after
Federal authorities threatened him with
11 years in prison for allegedly
violating the face act a federal crime
making it illegal to injure intimidate
or interfere with anyone due to their
status as a reproductive health care
provider months before a jury acquitted
the pro-life activist FBI agents in 15
Vehicles raided his residence quickly
throughout the house began pounding on
the door and demanding they open up
um
rather than reading more from this let's
let's listen to this testimony and I
want to start with this which is um how
describing the incident outside of the
abortion facility the abortion clinic
the abortionary as he calls it which I
think that's the best best term for it
so describing the incident that
eventually led to 15 FBI Vehicles
pulling up on his property guns drawn
dragged out of the house you know early
in the morning but here is what actually
happened listen
I want to bring you to October uh 13
2021 where I was with my son 12 year old
son
praying in front of an obituary in
Philadelphia on that day
a couple women walked out of the
facility I began to offer them
literature as I always do with
compassion love and great respect in
fact I was 50 feet away from the
entrance of the building
I'd proceeded to walk with those women
across the street making me about a
hundred feet away from the entrance to
the building to a Crisis Pregnancy
Center Pregnancy Resource Center which
is about six feet away from me at that
time an escort in the building decided
to run over
impede my progress and get in the way of
me ministering and talking to the women
that had left Planned Parenthood 12th
and Locust streets in Philadelphia
at that point we exchanged some words we
went back to where we were praying and I
continued to pray with my 12 year old
son
about 20 minutes later
the escort his name is Bruce love I've
known him for years I've known him for
20 years came out of the building
he made a direct line towards my son
stood right next to my son
again we're about 50 feet from the
entrance to the building
stood right next to my 12 year old boy
who was a little intimidated and scared
by this I asked him if he could please
give him some space he did not he has a
right to be there we just continued to
pray he continued to talk to me and
offer insults to me
which of course he's done before and it
was never a problem for me and I just I
didn't listen to it but then he started
to begin to talk to my son now he's
talked to my son before
in fact I believe he taught my son the f
word I'm a homeschool dad and that's the
reality of it nonetheless he begins to
talk to my son and Badger my son
and starts telling my son how evil his
father is
and how how his father doesn't want to
help women I instr instructed him to
step away and to go back to where he
normally stands in front of the building
which he did not he continued to Badger
my son
it's a repeated Quest not to comply not
not to stand next to my son I escorted
him back
to where he normally stands which he did
comply I turned around to face my son
and go back to pray and he turned around
and began to imagine my son again
at that point I became a dad on the
street concerned for my son I did push
the man he did fall down
Okay so
that's it that's what happened he was
being a protective dad he was just being
a normal dad he's been a good dad and he
shoved a jerk who was harassing his son
so what
um this guy
well first of all this guy clearly
deserved it you go up and you start
harassing a 12 year old boy with his dad
standing right there uh you you know
getting getting shoved you should be
you're lucky to get off just with a
shove okay it could be a lot worse than
that
um
but
even if you are somehow of the opinion
that Mark Halka overreacted and should
have been a little bit nicer to the man
that was cussing out his 12 year old son
is this is this do we need federal agent
is this a federal crime
is this something that that rises to
that level
you know companies are strong arming
their customers to support abortion
canceling customers for the political
views making a mockery of women by
supporting transgender models no
government agency institution or company
is allowed to be just what it is and
focus on fulfilling the tasks that it
was made to fulfill a beer company can't
just make beer anymore their primary
concern is not with brewing and
distributing beer but with showing their
support of the left's political and
cultural agenda Public Square is aware
of this problem and offers a new
solution Public Square is an app and a
website where you can get connected to
tens of thousands of businesses from all
different industries that share your
value for Life freedom and family Public
Square also offers discounts to many
high quality businesses on the platform
so you can actually have an incentive to
spend money with companies that don't
hate you so it's a win-win situation
there whether you're looking for a new
athletic clothing that knows what a
woman is or a banking partner that you
can count on or simply a new restaurant
in your area that won't lecture you
about your political views as you're
trying to enjoy a meal with your family
whether you gotta head over to
publicsq.com Public Square is free to
join as a consumer or a business owner
you can get started at publicsq.com or
download their app today that's
publicsq.com the one year anniversary of
Roe v Wade being overturned is coming up
and since then the left has completely
lost their mind pro-life efforts which
are more important now than ever ever
are booming you heard that right despite
the narrative pro-lifers didn't go away
they have only increased in number four
days for life is changing hearts and
Minds in the most blue pro-abortion
States they've had a record number of
locations since row was overturned and
they've grown in both volunteers and
locations again that's ever since the
overturning of Roe v Wade with about 1
million Volunteers in 1500 cities they
hold peaceful vigils outside of abortion
facilities the success has come with new
unwanted attention from the federal
government and the doj in regards to
free speech as the as one of the largest
pro-life organizations in the world no
one is in better position than 40 Days
for life to end abortion in each state
in a post-rural America you can help
them fight the ongoing legal battles of
protecting free free speech for their
volunteers including Mark Houck uh the
40 Days for Life volunteer who had his
house raided by the FBI that we talked
about today you can help them defend
free speech by getting a tax deductible
gift of any amount at 40daysforlife.com
that's 40daysforlife.com
and by the way this Dynamic here is very
very common okay so if you're not
familiar with pro-life activism you
haven't been around pro-life activists
and you get your impression of them from
the media and I would hope that you'd be
smart enough to know that you can't
trust that impression but if that is
where you get it then then then you
probably imagine
um
that usually a situation is reversed
because in this case Mark howkins signed
their their peacefully and quietly and
they're praying and you've got this
belligerent this Bruce love guy
who's the uh the Clinton a volunteer
escort and what that means is that he
his whole job that many of these people
do for free is they they go up and they
show up on Saturday mornings and early
mornings abortion clinics and they
escort women into the abortion clinic
and their whole job
is to make sure that those women are not
exposed to any kind of literature or any
conversations or any information that
will tell them more about what they're
going to do because that's all that you
know on the other end we have the
sidewalk counselors pro-life sidewall
counselors all they want to do is uh
they're not running up and screaming at
the women they're not cussing them out
they're not telling them you're in
burning hell
all they want to do is provide them with
information like okay this is what an
abortion is this is what you're about to
do
here's information about that and here
here are other there are other options
so we want to they want to give
information and inform them of their
other options
the clinic doesn't want that clinic
doesn't want any of that they want these
women coming in uh scared and ignorant
and thinking that they have no other
choice but they have to do it right they
want them scared ignorant and helpless
and the clinic escorts are there to
assist in that
now why would someone volunteer their
time to this you know volunteer your
time
you know on a Saturday morning
to escorting women into an abortion
clinic to kill their babies
you're volunteering your time to make
sure that women are are not informed
about these kinds of decisions
well this just shows you the fact that
they that somebody like this other guy
that they're they're that passionate
about abortion just shows you how evil
they are
and so it shouldn't surprise you to
learn that this is normally the way that
it goes the pro-life uh activists who
are on the scene at these abortion
clinics
vast majority of cases they are peaceful
they are quiet they are respectful
okay I've been around a lot of these
people all over the country and this is
in almost every case peaceful quiet
respectful prayerful
the belligerents the violence the
aggressiveness is almost always coming
from the other side
um
and that's what happened here
and that led to the uh
to eventually the FBI getting involved
before the FBI got involved another
important thing to to keep in mind is
that local prosecutors and Philadelphia
not exactly a friendly environment for
pro-lifers uh the the D.A I'm not sure
who was the D.A at the time but we can
assume not someone who's on the same
side ideologically as pro-life activists
and but they they found that there were
there's they were gonna they did they
were not going to file any charges they
weren't going to press charges because
they didn't see that there were any
charges to press
um
sometime later the feds came back around
and decided they wanted to get involved
and that's what led to uh this
on September 23rd my home was rated by
unmarked and marked units state troopers
federal law enforcement Personnel I had
five federal agents on my doorstep at 6
30 in the morning with long guns pointed
at me and my seven children
they banged on the door and they said
open up they did not even declare who
they were that day they didn't even ask
me uh could you please open the door
with the FBI they just said open up
I went to the door I was up
I said who is it they said is the FBI
open up so I opened up the door
peacefully I said please stay calm I
have seven babies in here they pointed
M16 guns at me and my wife my wife comes
down says do you have a warrant for his
arrest
they said we're taking him with or
without a warrant
my wife said you can't do that that's
kidnapping we proceeded to go into a
four and a half month trial uh that
would as you know and and have said uh
previously that we were acquitted of but
I was facing 11 years in prison and I
had every uh Prospect in my heart that I
would be in federal prison away from my
several seven children
um yeah they won this is what Biden
wanted Biden Biden it didn't work out
for him but uh thank God didn't work out
for everybody but what he wanted was
this guy hauled away
in handcuffs in front of this terrified
children he got that part of it uh and
then he wanted him in prison for a
decade he wanted to take this man away
from his kids for a decade because he
shoved because he shoved someone who was
accosting his 12 year old son
um
as I said at the beginning there are
many examples of miscarriages of justice
of government agencies being weaponized
against political opponents we talk we
talk a lot about about the cases that
involve Trump and for good reason
however
um
this is one of the worst cases and this
man's name should be well known I mean
this should be like a household name
among conservatives
um and it is a potentially a very
terrifying glimpse into the future
because it's not like they're done you
know it didn't work out they weren't
able to to get him in prison for 11
years like they wanted to
but
um
they're not gonna stop
I remember they they went looking for
this case
okay it happened the local prosecutor
said we're not going to press charges
everybody moved on
as far as we know everyone kind of moved
on and months and months later the the
bite Administration went looking it's
like let's find somebody who we can make
an example of under this face act thing
and they and they found him
and by the way the fact that they were
looking they were looking to send a
message again to pro-lifers to
intimidate them try to make an example
out of somebody and the fact that they
had to choose Mark Hulk
only goes to show how peaceful uh and um
you know how peaceful pro-lifers
always are
because from what the media tells us you
would think that there'd be many
examples of pro-lifers violating the
face act and you know uh running into
the abortion clinics and causing a scene
and all the rest of it
the fact they had to go for him that
this was the case they had to try they
had to uh they had to
they had to try uh I think shows you
shows you everything and I'll do it for
this portion of the shows and move over
to the members block hope to see you
there if not talk to you uh tomorrow
Godspeed